Counter-Strike two
[Music]
before we get into this video and I am
dying to get into this video an
extremely topical friendly reminder that
the scoring Sports has a CS2 face a clan
check out the link in the description
below to join play with me your friends
and the rest of our community so you can
find Reliable teammates climb the
leaderboards win points and spend them
in the face it shot okay
CS2 it's here officially CS go is gone
the servers have been shut down
permanently which I'm not gonna lie was
a surprisingly emotional moment CS go
was probably the most important
influential and well greatest shooter
ever made full stop I still think that
1.6 felt better than go but even I
cannot deny the world altering impact
the Global Offensive had on FPS Esports
and indeed gaming at large so before we
set forth into CS2 let's just take one
more second and bid farewell to well the
goat I think that CS go was and forever
will be the goat and I think I speak for
everyone when I say
thank you now
on to the next chapter Midway through
complexity in Monty's ESL pro league
vote valve pushed the full release of
CS2 that they'd teased last Wednesday
and dude the trailer they put out
this one hit right right in the
Nostalgia fields for those of us who've
been playing since 1.6 oh shout out to
machine for just absolutely sending it
on this one
for over two decades Counter-Strike has
offered an elite competitive Experience
One shaped by millions of players from
across the globe and now the next
chapter in the Cs story is about to
begin this
Counter-Strike two so yeah CS2 has
replaced CS go on Steam that's sort of
if now to be clear this is a very big
deal the game is now no longer in beta
literally everyone can play it and CS2
is now the domain of professional play
which
don't even get me started on how insane
that is I say that because the game will
inevitably continue to be very buggy and
we are bound to get some Olaf
boost-esque moments in the coming weeks
months
years I don't know anyway aside from the
pro scene which none of us have any of
our bearings on yet there are a few
other things to talk about for starters
anyone who opened CS2 coming from go was
greeted with a complimentary CS Go music
kit and service badge what's more valve
changed like all of the skin icons and
implemented a seemingly infinite number
of skin touch-ups I'll be honest might
actually be one of the biggest things
about this launch Skins are finally
starting to look less plasticky and are
just cleaner across the board in fact
some of us are already farming them in
droves
oh my God oh my God
track red
track red you should tweet that I tweet
it out right now stat track rant the
first one live on Counter-Strike two
please like And subscribe
guys
get it out three two one
oh my God oh my God
[Music]
oh my God the first one in CS2 they also
added Community servers think
God my dude if I had to run one more
round of this stupid official
matchmaking Death Match thing I was
gonna switch to valorum dude I swear to
God they also implemented this thing
called a care package which gives you
weekly rewards as you increase your XP
rank now valve did release a full set of
release notes which I really encourage
you to go through there's a lot of
really important little touch-ups here
things like fixing player to player
Collision the different animations that
happen when you're jiggle peeking and
jumping and of course chickens can
finally fall off of vertigo but aside
from that there's not much for now which
I mean I'll be honest is like a tad bit
deflating you know I waited all day for
valve's tweet just like the rest of you
and when I saw it I did kind of say like
that's it those new Knives have been
leaked for some time and I was kind of
hoping we might get our first set of CS2
specific skins look was I hoping for a
full-blown operation yeah yeah I was am
I a little disappointed we didn't get
any new content
a bit but I understand that getting this
thing out the door was valve's top
priority and that doing so was an
achievement in itself the important
thing is that CS2 is here valve did it
there will be plenty of time in the
coming weeks to analyze every aspect of
the game and release videos accordingly
but that's not for today for today it
suffices to say that the foundation has
been late so let's just take a moment
celebrate that because for a long time
it really felt like Source two or
Counter-Strike 2 was a meme it was a
pipe dream this thing that was never
ever going to happen
but it wasn't it's here it's a reality
and now it's for everyone to enjoy
so enjoy
when I open up steam I was like wait
till they just supplanted one for the
other I opened it and then I saw the
music hit and then I saw the badge and I
was like all right and then I actually
had this moment when I saw the icons
change that's what threw me off they
changed all of the skin icons in the
game like you're in the inventory so I
had this moment I was like
like what the like wait what like
everything just changed it was actually
very jarring it was like really weird